[Music]
[Applause]
reggie miller will be on the call
tonight with kevin harlan and stan van
gundy western conference finals it'll be
game four
in dallas at nine eastern on tnt before
we get to that reg thanks for joining us
it's a big night win or lose we
celebrate tonight just want to let you
know that you will be there with us in
spirit at the sports emmys
we
are the champions
my friend
look
they cannot stop denying greatness
and gentlemen they are great they have
reg they they have but they cannot keep
on doing it that's my point okay we have
now
but tonight is the night theodore right
we're popping bob i am gonna have me
a bottle of dum on air okay i want you
to text me after we win and i'm gonna
have the camera panned to me and i am
popping this bob
on air okay it's gonna be about 45
minutes after tip-off when we're going
to hear if we've won or not
just letting you know around 9 45
eastern
i'll let my producer know it is on okay
we are the champions okay all right uh
can you go out to a strip club
after you've lost a game
in the playoffs and you have a game the
next night
well there's two schools tell me what
the
the series is what
3-0 like
three no we're up or three no
down 3-0 it was the florida panthers
they lost to the tampa bay lightning so
they just came off a loss it's 5-1 they
reportedly went out to a strip club and
then they got shut out last night got
eliminated first round
so no often
there's two schools of thoughts here
okay either number one you have one foot
on air canada or air cancun right now
you have one foot on air cancun
and you're like we're down 3-0
it's over let's go have some fun
gentlemen or
number two
we've tried everything else being
isolated and you know being hunkered
down for the playoffs and that did not
work
let's
break the ice have some fun
and try to get one game
maybe that was the school aside okay if
you're asking me no you cannot go to a
strip club during the playoffs when
you're down but those could be the two
schools of thoughts that
these guys are probably thinking well
it's like when jordan went to atlantic
city
and then came back after gambling until
2 30 in the morning new york times wrote
about it but michael won
therefore
it was okay if he had lost then they
probably would have been uh pretty harsh
on on him
in today's age of social media with
instagram tick tock and everything is
instant
very difficult to do
it would have been interesting if social
media was back in our day um because i'm
sure oh ooh i'm sure there's a lot of
things that
i look back on now is like nope can't do
that uh no can't do that oh wish i could
do that it can't uh um
so yeah it's very difficult in today's
age to do some of the things that i was
allowed to get away with
but but the bulls were down 0-2 reg
jordan goes to atlantic city uh atlantic
city comes back after the article comes
out and the bulls win four straight
so that we should
it is okay to go to a strip club down
all the time i want to be like come back
yeah i want to be like mike okay i want
to be like mike i'm watching the game
last night and at some point eric
spoelstra has to say to his starting
five
we're not gonna we're not gonna be
competitive tonight we're not gonna play
anymore
how do you say that to your team how
would you feel if eric spoelstra said
reg
got to sit down we're not gonna win this
game let's uh let's get ready for game
five in miami
uh truthfully you probably didn't have
to say it to those guys they probably
went to eric's poster and said coach
uh i think i'm gonna be holding the
clipboard next to you the rest of the
second half this series
it reminds me a lot of my series versus
the knicks in the 90s both teams
excellent defensively and every
possession is like a a game within a
game it's a battle and
i think if you were miami coming into
game three
with the series tied 1-1 you just wanted
to even the series up and regain home
court advantage which they did
and i think they left a lot on the table
in that game and this was a i hate to
say it a throwaway game right we already
recaptured home court so whatever
happens happens
we will see a much better effort
by miami in game five because the series
is two tied two two and we know the
winner of game five
generally wins this series what 77
percent of the time
so obviously we'll see a better effort
back in south beach by miami but let's
face it they gave they just threw this
game away because they had already
recaptured home court
you had no problem then with them sort
of mailing it in and
just we'll regroup for game five they
play so hard at the defensive end
um
it's hard to expend that kind of energy
and i know it you know there's less than
48 hours
you know before the next game but it's
difficult you know when you live
possession by possession
and as great as jimmy butler is and the
injuries are mounting up for both teams
it's tough to
you know go 100 miles an hour for 48
minutes when they play like that it's
not like it's golden state where the
offense is flowing there's ball movement
it's not that this this series is going
to be one in the trenches
and it's going to be fun to watch game
five because it's really going to be
last man standing
if you look at both of these rosters and
what's you know
major players
you know having to overcome adversity
and play so it's fun to watch but it's
fun to see like
who's really in it right theodore like
who's really tough enough to finish this
out that's why i'm intrigued by this
series okay who do you think would give
the golden state warriors should they
advance
a better challenge in the nba finals
both
well you got to pick one defensively but
pick one who has the better chance to
beat golden state
i wow
i okay i will say this
i still believe miami is going to win
that series but who would give golden
state a better
series i think boston because they have
more offensive weapons okay i just don't
i'm not in love
jimmy butler to me is
the only main offensive weapon
for miami
but you got tatum you got you know
jaylen brown
you got two guys that could absolutely
score the basketball i think that would
be probably a better series versus
golden state
but i don't think they're going to be
able to get by miami i look i could be
wrong
but i'm not getting off the uncle jimmy
bandwagon
if you're golden state are you all in to
win this game
or do you
say let's let's see what we can do and
if we feel like it's slipping away then
we'll regroup and we'll head back home
and win this in five
i think that'll be the approach
but if you're steve kerr and the
warriors think about i mean you know for
a fact
that that e series is going at least six
and you've got some banged up players
otto porter jr went down last game
uh andre iguodala has not played in this
series and gary payton
the second because the elbow injury has
not played so if you can find a way to
win this and sweep in four
you buy time for those guys to get
better
but on the flip side
you're up 3-0
it's human nature
to let your foot off the gas and say you
know what
worst case scenario we have two or three
games at home if something was to happen
to win this series
we could very much well win this in five
games back home and reward our fans by
clinching this series in our building i
could see that happening
but this is where you fall into a trap
because you're a twisted ankle away
from something happening that's why you
try to put all your eggs in to sweep in
a team but people don't understand how
difficult it is
to
win two times on an opposing team's
floor back to back which golden state is
trying to do
reggie miller the hall of famers on the
call tonight western conference finals
it starts at 9 00 eastern on tnt with
kevin harland stan van gundy this is how
it sounded last game
with reggie on the call with kevin
harlan brunson defends snaps it outside
to wiggins goes by
bullets drops the sledgehammer
oh
my goodness i've got to see this again
what'd you make of that call there
wrench
mark davis the official he dropped the
ball
no seriously because there's a that
should have been
an and one and he
for them to take
10 minutes to replay
and go back and then overturn it
again it didn't take away from it
because it was such a spectacular finish
in dunk by andrew wiggins
but it easily could have been marred
because if steve kerr didn't have his
challenge to be able to challenge it
it wouldn't have counted right yeah
yeah so mark davis dropped the ball
because
that was an absolute that's the could be
the dunk of the year okay is that better
better than john moran's
wow
yeah because it's deeper in the playoffs
you know
it's
yeah
do you if you look at that play
look where he's he started from yeah i
mean he is two or three feet
extended from
the charred circle
unbelievable effort yeah i would have to
say it's better than john moran luke
could try and uh and on top of that
and the sad thing about it is you've got
two premier players doing it andrew
wiggins and it wasn't like he was doing
this on maxi cleaver or davos for tens
that's luca underneath there that's a
luca
yeah in name only he doesn't have the
athleticism to be going up there he does
it but it's a name player it's a body
yeah it's a body you could say that was
luca doncic underneath there okay can
can the mavs win
with this rock can they win a
championship with this roster
no
what would you add in the off-season
i think you need first of all you got to
find a way to sign jalen brunson if
that's what your plan is because
uh he's the number two as we currently
speak on this team
and
you've got to get more consistent
shooting
and i love me some reggie block but you
can't go over ten over seven for three
if you're maxi uh
clever you can't go
oh for five from three i mean those guys
were o for twelve and this team is
predicated on knocking down threes
so more consistency and you've gotta
bring in
a fringe superstar to be able to play
with luca
i applaud them for getting to the
conference finals with this roster i
mean this is the same team that beat the
overall number one team phoenix suns by
like 40 points in game seven
on their floor
so i applaud them for even getting this
far do they win a championship with this
roster
no and i think
the further you go in the playoffs you
know where you know this cream rises
right and your warts and your faults
they start to rise to the surface and
we're kind of seeing that right now with
the mavericks if you were playing
against steph curry and he shimmied and
turned his back after he you know took a
three-pointer chewing on his mouthpiece
how would that go over reg if you're
guarding steph curry and he did that
stuff
there was a player i played against who
was
somewhat similar to this and i
i to this day i tell people he was my
hardest cover and i hated him
because let's let's try to guess let's
try to guess
paulie you want to guess oh um
i just thought the name that popped in
my head was nick van exus all right i'm
gonna go nick van x i'm gonna go vernon
maxwell
no no he has a game but he has the game
okay those guys didn't have the game
okay marv i'm gonna go drazin petrovic
oh there it is
absolutely
mad with his antics okay because he was
so
good at scoring the basketball right in
my face and talking junk right in my ear
and it just drove me crazy
and
god bless steph and i love it i have i
love the antics wait you would have no
problem if he embarrassed you like that
yes i'm telling you i had a problem with
rather than petrovic
and i would have a problem but if you're
that good do something about it that's
what drugs used to say do something
about it
and there was a lot of times there
wasn't a lot i could do about it
so if you're upset with it do something
about it
see here's the problem in the 90s you
would get love tapped all that stuff you
know what he was doing
i would just tell my davis voice i'm
gonna let i'm gonna let him beat me i
probably wouldn't say i'm gonna let him
beat me anyway
and i would
and they would have send a message in
today's game you can't do that because
everything goes to the review and the
flagrant one you can't anyone above the
shoulders
there would be love taps being
being delivered you can't do that in
today's game so steph can shimmy and
shake all he wants because there's no
repercussion
if steph wins another title this time
without kd
let's say he's mvp of the finals like
now we're getting into rarified air now
you're knocking on the door there's a
door there you know there's levels of
doors
in
in the upper echelon okay
does he does he open the top ten door of
all time with another title
and finals mvp
yes oh okay
who comes out of the top who has to
leave no no one comes out no one comes
out wait but he's going into the top ten
so somebody's got to come out
what
oh so there's only 10 people in this
door in the vip area
who would come out
okay well let's decide who the
10 are obviously
jordan russell
kobe
duncan
shack
bird magic
bird magic is that seven okay
wilt is he in there
is wilt over hakeem
in this
well i'd love akima so i would have him
too i would have him in there too he's
not he's not in the top ten he's not
listed as the team
all right we're at we're at a hard seven
right now what's the what's the ten like
consensus yeah consensus top ten
uh shaq's in there a lot of people have
tim duncan a lot of people have kobe
bryant no duncan should be in there and
kobe yeah yeah we have uh i've said all
those larry bird we're at a hard seven
right now
so you got
jordan russell
oscar robertson
both only have one championship
who else is in there paulie that's
pretty much unless you like magic when
you start getting hakeem
and and jerry west you're now in the i
don't think
here's a guy who will have won four
two-time league mvp is he in the top 10.
if he does that one-time finals mvp yeah
and the the the distinction of the
greatest and it's no debate the greatest
shooter of all time i've got to say he
would be in that discussion of it of the
top ten
yeah
yes i would yeah i i i think bird might
be expendable
have you been watching winning time
i look i love birds
it's it's longevity
are you taking duncan out you're taking
kobe or magic
no jack
by default they're in magic because they
will forever be linked will forever be
in because they changed
and they've made sure we've all
prospered afterwards michael will never
be out russell will never be out
and i think duncan will never be out
shaq can never be out
kobe can never be out yes paulie kobe
bryant has one league mvp and five times
five titles
steph curry's one time scoring steph
curry would if he won this year let's
say he would have four titles two league
mvps
a unanimous one and a finals mvp yeah
but was it kobe two-time finals mvp
yes
boom baby
can never be out all right that's a good
good good let's see if he uh he gets
there yeah there's a lot of work still
to be done okay yeah absolutely starting
tonight on tnt 9 eastern um i'll
[Music]
i'll text you we'll be at the strip club
win or lose we celebrate that's our
motto
oh give mandy
now we go for a budget
like a budgetary strip club
not if we win we gotta think big that's
the problem we haven't been thinking big
general man
thank you reg have fun tonight
appreciate you guys
that's reggie aloysius miller jr iii
if if that would actually happen where
we win and we text him and then he pops
some champagne
that would be awesome